des centaines de personnes venues rendre
un dernier hommage à l'ancien dirigeant
de l'union soviétique et citoyens de
tous âges ont déposé des roses devant le
cercueil ouvert la fille de mikhaïl
gorbatchev est à 6 tout près aucun jour
de deuil national a été décrétée pour
celui qui a reçu le prix nobel de la
paix en 1990 notre charme au creusot il
n'y a pas eu de discours personne n'a
parlé de ses réalisations de son
importance pour le monde j'ai été
surpris cérémonie ressemblait davantage
aux funérailles d'un homme important
mais pas d'un personnage d'état
parmi les quelques dignitaires le
premier ministre hongrois viktor orban
le président russe vladimir poutine
brillait par son absence
il s'est contenté de se recueillir
discrètement devant la dépouille jeudi
dernier
gorbatchev est arrivé au pouvoir en 1985
et il a précipité malgré lui la
disparition de l' empire soviétique
mettant fin à la guerre froide
[Applaudissements]
l'occident le considère comme une figure
politique majeure du xxème siècle mais
bien des russes jette un autre regard
sur lui il le voit comme celui qui
affaiblit leur pays devant les
américains néanmoins beaucoup ont
souligné son héritage politique oui
pourvu qu'il est comme tout son règne
nous avons eu un souffle de liberté
je lui suis reconnaissant de nous avoir
donné la glace nost pluralisme et la
paix je suis pour l'ouverture pour le
dialogue c'est ce que gorbatchev a
montré au monde
il a été enterré au cimetière de
novodevitchi à moscou aux côtés de son
épouse ici mélissa françois radio canada
montréal
[Musique]